اذا معانا هنا في الاستديو الدكتور فرقه
نجم اهلا بك وايضا الدكتور احمد الصيدلي
حياك الله والدكتور احمد الوسطى
صبحكم الله بالخير اليوم يعني نطلع من
العياده نروح ناخذ شيء مسكن كتافلام ولا
شنو
الارتباط يعني بالصبح ما بين الاسنان وما
بين توصفون هذه الادويه وبالليل تاخذون
هوايتكم ولا خلاص صارت احترافيه بالليل
الصبح اليوم بدنا نغني يعني والله
لا بس شو علاقه الطب والصيدله وطب الاسنان
تحديدا بالفن ليه يعني هو كل انسان بداخله
فنان صغير حلو لازم يعرف هو شنو الموهبه
اللي عنده بس يدور عليها انا مواهبي دفين
عشان نكتشفها يلا زين انا خلني اسالكم
سؤال وهذا يعني سؤال يقولون والله فرقه
وتر
تعيد ما تم غنائه في الثمانينات
السبعينات الثمانينات برضى الخياط وغيره
من الفنانين لكن
بمفردات جديده على الاقل مو هذه المفردات
الثقيله كما يقال اللي كانت في الاغنيه
العراقيه صحيح احمد الاسطل يلا احمد
الاسطى انت مزعل البيض على فكره رايح بس
للسمر
العراقيين معروفين بالسمار يعني احنا نحكي
على الاغلبيه يعني وين الاغلبيه عاده تفضل
يعني احمد الاسطى من مواليد الثمانينات
يعتبر يعني رجال كبير مو شاب صغير
انا اخوتي الاكبر من عندي انا يعني صغيره
باخوتي واخوتي كبار كانوا يسمعون الياس
خضر يسمعون الرضا الخياط سمعون السعد
الحلي فمن انا الطفل كانت تمر على مسامعي
هاي الاغاني فمتاثر بيها جدا فما تغيرت
حبيت انه اكمل هاي المسيره ودعمني بهذا
الموضوع الاستاذ جمعه العربي تحياتي له
والموسيقار الشيخ الموسيقين الاستاذ فاروق
هلال قالوا لاحمد يعني معتمدين عليك انه
اللون والحمد لله اني نجحت في كتابه
الاغنيه السبعينيه المحدثه مثل ما دامك
نسمعها هي اغانيكم انتم كلمات
[موسيقى]
ما دامك يحبين
هل ممكن تبوسين
هل ممكن تخليني
ارسم سمايا عيوني واقسم قسم ماخو هل ممكن
اكتب
قلبي واصير النبض
صيريلي عيني وعيني ما دامت تحبي
صغيرين عيني وعيني ما دامت تحبيني
ما د
هل ممكن تبوسين هل ممكن تخليني ارسم سما
يا عيوني واقسم قسم ما اخونك هل ممكن اكتب
اسمي قلبي قلبي واصير النبضي صيني لي عيني
وعيني ما دامت تحبي
تصيرين عيني وعيني ما دامك تحبي
[موسيقى]
خايف
طاير
طاير بحبك طاير يا حلوه يا امير وبحالي
مدري ايش صاير اكتب شعر تغنى يا نداركم
واتعنى جيران حسوا
خسراني روحه وجيه وانا احلف لهم بالله يا
عمي صفوا النيه ايران حسوا بيا فجروني
روحه وجيه وانا احلف لهم بالله يا عمي
صفوا النيه ما دام تحبيني
هل ممكن تقولي
هل ممكن تخليني
[موسيقى]
عيوني
هل ممكن اكذبي قلبي واصير النبضي صيرين
عيني وع
ما دامك تحبيني
صيني لعيني وعيني ما دامك تحبيني
[موسيقى]
وشو هالاناجه على فكره في طاقه فظيعه
يعني
كان في عندكم خلفيه موسيقيه فنيه اكيد عم
تعزفوا الات يعني تعلمتوا هذا الشيء بشكل
احترافي ولا كله موهبه وجهد شخصي
بدنا نحكي عني فهي موهبه اولا وانا لا
درست يعني موسيقى درستها بعدين لان انا
صار 30 سنه موسيقي انا من عمري 11 12 سنه
بلشت الموسيقى
ترى انا ما لي علاقه انت حتى غني الشايب
يعني خليني لا ما هو قال الثمانينات طيب
خليني اسال انه انت احمد لما يكتب الاغنيه
اكتبها لتريو لفرقه وتر ولا يكتبها لشخص
واحد يغنيها
زين خلصنا الان من ما دامك تحبيني تحدي
الجاي ايش راح يكون صح
مذهب
جوده يلا عدل
احنا طبعا نشكركم لانه رح نخليكم مع
الجمهور ختام جزيلا طبعا شباب فرقه وتر ما
شاء الله عليكم ومشاهدينا شكرا على حسن
المتابعه نراكم في الغرب
[موسيقى]
يا لونك الحنطاوي خلي الوضع ماساوي يا
لونك الحنطاوي خلي الوضع ماساوي عوفي
السوالف والعتب لعيونك يهون
السوالف
لعيونك يهون التعب احكي لي على الطاحه
وعشق شو نعوف يا هونداوي
احكيلي على القاحه
وعشيل عوف يا هونداوي يا لونك الحنطاوي
خلى الوضع ماساوي يا لونك الحنطاوي خلي
الوضع مساوي عوفي سواليف والعتب لعيوني
جيهون
السوالف والعجل لعيون
التعب احكي
احكيلي علطاحه وعشت شلعوف يا هونداوي
سويلم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات